[Musique]
le point commun avec toutes ces
personnes qui se rassemblent près du
village corail c'est bien l'espoir
malgré des contextes parfois difficile
mama
l'as tefana moi et me croyais pas ce
monsieur théâtre ses premiers fois que
ce fut le théâtre avant l'été
informations aide ménagère premier
formation je suis fan de théâtre depuis
toujours que je suis petit léger les
jeunes et qui a eu le coc u19 tout ça ma
petite entreprise à du vin coulait un
petit peu et dont je me suis dit il faut
voir il va falloir que je trouve quelque
chose qui ait un lien avec la musique
[Musique]
tous en situation de demandeur d'emploi
ses bénéficiaires du rsa se sont engagés
depuis janvier dans cet atelier était de
créer un atelier chantier d'insertion
autour du spectacle autour de la culture
pour permettre
à un public en fait bénéficiaires des
minima sociaux le rsa la ss de découvrir
la culture et dès qu'on entre on est
dans l'état
un an vous développez la séquence vous
êtes chacun dans votre votre bulle des
faits vous pensez qu'il ya le projet sur
la tête qui voit là nous avons un thème
choisi avec l'ensemble du groupe qui est
la violence et les addictions
à partir de ce thème j'ai cherché à
susciter la créativité de chacun et de
fabriquer un objet artistique d'ensemble
qui parle de toutes les formes de
violence et d addiction
le contenu la ressource n'a été donnée
par les participants à partir de nos
expériences nous partons de nous pour
jouer en fait c'est une représentation
de la vie mieux dans leur peau ils se
projettent sur des objectifs
le théâtre est ici un vecteur
d'épanouissement un passeport pour
avancer la distance est vraiment
beaucoup quand même
why immigrés ont bien regardé la dalle
des gentils groupe super on apprend à
vivre en collectif on apprend à jouer
ensemble ça permet de développer de
débloquer certaines choses ça ça me fait
du bien la santé ça ça me je suis
m'apprend à me connaître encore plus en
fait on apprend à aimer son corps
apprendre à connaître son corps
moralement et donc ça c'est une première
découverte dans quelques semaines une
représentation est prévue au village
corail d'ici là les projets
professionnels avancent accélère au
niveau de l'accompagnement
socioprofessionnel pas tout on pourra
faire du théâtre du chant donc notre
objectif est de travailler sur leur vrai
projet professionnel
donc en fait on la déteste en interne
qu'à leur permettre en fait de découvrir
leur métier
ensuite ils font une immersion en
entreprise pour valider le projet et
puis ils iront vers soi une formation
ouvert un emploi l'assemblage de tous
est ses morceaux ces fragments de vie
confronté à d alain violence raconte
quelque chose qui nous concerne tous
dans notre rapport à la violence et aux
addictions
j'étais parti j'ai entendu des ratés
envers les banques fassent pas bon
bonjour même arthur le mec de l'eau le
directionnel internet voudrait bien fait
qu'on y tient si possible imv effet 10 4
comment là j'aimerais bien un jour faire
quelque chose là dedans quoi j'aimerais
bien bon mais l'avenir moi je prépare
mon âge je prépare mon troisième album
tout doucement sur moi je vole coiffante
papillon bah je sais pas ce que l'avenir
va me réserver mais j'attends la
surprise quoi en ce moment par rapport à
la situation ben il faut être
il faut être soit parfois le coup de
pouce qui compte passe par de tels
moments de vie il leur appartient
maintenant de faire grandir cette flamme
[Musique]